buenas tardes la situación sigue siendo
muy delicada aquí en el reino unido- de
las últimas 24 horas el país acumuló
casi 40.000 nuevos casos de contagios
especialmente en zonas donde no había
habido ese incremento entonces por ello
a partir del sábado 26 de diciembre
habrá entonces más restricciones muchas
más estrictas para el este y el sureste
del país este era un día esperado por
todos los comerciantes porque ofrecen
grandes promociones entonces ese día ya
no existirá ya habrá entonces entrado en
vigencia este nuevo confinamiento la
gente debe estar en las casas los
comercios no esenciales como les digo
estarán cerrados no se puede viajar
dentro de inglaterra dentro del reino
unido- y salvo por estricta causa mayor
fuera del país y no se pueden mezclar
con personas que no se convivan
louis ay qué información hay sobre esta
posible segunda variante de coronavirus
que fue encontrada en el reino unido-
que es diferente a la variante que
habíamos reportado la semana pasada
aparentemente se trata de una variante
procedente de sudáfrica
si es otra variante distinta como lo
mencionas los gobiernos de reino unido y
de sudáfrica están trabajando con los
equipos científicos para conocer más
detalles sobre esta nueva variante se
sabe como lo mencionas que es
proveniente de sudáfrica dos personas
que habrían arribado al país en los
últimos días son los portadores y por
ello les han pedido a quienes han
llegado de ese país en las últimas dos
semanas y quienes han tenido contacto
con ellas que estén en estricto
confinamiento además el gobierno
británico ha impuesto restricciones de
viaje a ese país africano y por supuesto
es una noticia en evolución porque no se
tiene mayor información sobre este virus
salvo que es altamente contagioso más
detalles los tendremos en las próximas
horas por parte de las autoridades
británicas muchas gracias luisa por este
reporte desde la ciudad de londres